(upbeat music)
- So usually when I have
a first time volunteer
come and be a part of a class
and their face says it all.
They're like, "Oh my gosh,
that was the coolest thing
"I've ever been a part of."
'Cause it's just a joyful place.
(bright upbeat music)
My name is Lauren Beasley
and I'm the founder
and executive director
of Move Inclusive Dance
Move Inclusive Dance is a
dance studio for everyone,
no matter their ability level.
But I took my first dance class
when I was three years old.
From that point on, it was
pretty much my everything.
For me, not only was it,
you know, a fun activity,
but it was the place where I could go
and know that it was safe for
me to express my emotions,
be myself, and it was just
really a creative outlet.
It was way more than just learning steps.
Not everyone loves to dance,
but a lot of people do.
It's the same for people
with disabilities, right?
Why wouldn't there be a
place that they could go
take a dance class like I can?
They don't have that opportunity.
And because it was so
transformative in my life,
I felt like it was my duty at that point
to make it possible.
When we start the choreography,
what's the very first thing
that we do in this combo?
Yes Emma show them we slide and we party.
We slide and we party.
(camera clicks)
When I'm driving to the studio,
I'm probably planning
my classes for the day.
One of the things that is different
when you're teaching adaptive dance,
you wanna have a good solid plan,
but you also have to be prepared
for literally anything else
to happen just in case,
plan A doesn't really go,
as I thought, and you just gotta be ready
to move on your toes like that.
- I oversee all of the programming here
at Move Inclusive Dance.
I'm seeing if all the students
are getting their needs met.
You have to get to know the student
in order to understand
exactly what they need.
And that's what inclusion is all about.
It's a dance class, but it's adapting
to whoever is coming through the doors.
- We've tailored everything that we do
everything in the building,
every part of our curriculum
to be adapted for people
with special needs,
but at the same time,
people without special needs
are also welcome in the classes too.
Yes we go.
One one and two.
From here, we do a little kick
combination with our feet.
So if you're doing the
feet, it'll look like this
you go kick forward, take
sides and then change it up.
Again, go forward and side
and then change it up.
And if you're just doing the upper body,
you're gonna kinda just like...
(vocalizing)
Switch sides, (vocalizing), switch sides.
- Building a better
community and a better place
is the ultimate goal.
- No matter where you come from,
what ability level you have, you fit here.
We're going to make dance work for you.
But when things shut down due to COVID,
we immediately had to pivot.
And so we took things
to a virtual setting.
Can someone tell me
what's improv dance is?
Raise your hand if you know.
- It is the way you just
dance without any instruction.
- Yes, it's when you dance
without any instruction,
that's a really good description of it.
You know, it's definitely not
the same as being in person.
But what I've found is that
people right now more than ever
are craving connection.
Our students that are
doing the zoom classes,
they love their weekly sessions
because they get to see their friends.
We've had a handful of
students that have participated
from out of state because
we're doing it online, right?
So you can really join from anywhere.
And that's been a really,
really cool thing to see
because it's just opened our program up.
It just requires a lot of
energy from me as the teacher.
I am like worn out by the end
of one of our virtual classes.
(upbeat music)
Let's do this, just follow me.
(bright upbeat music)
We use dance to get our message out there.
But at the end of the day,
we just want people to
be open to one another,
love one another and be positive.
(bright upbeat music)